ich war heute bei uns zu hause haben
zusammen noch mit aktuell ein video
aufgenommen bei denen jahren hinter der
kamera sitzt und einen ford sagt und ihr
vor der kamera müssen abwechselnd
anonyme sagen also hier erstmal die
leute die mit dabei sind und dann geht's
los update verliert bei fifa gegen seine
katze luca denkt dass emos im zoo leben
schenkt es verführt jedes mädchen mit
seinem grinsen
[Musik]
ja ja ja ja zeichengerät
bitte gebäude wo meine wird die eigenen
vier wände eine tüte nein weil ich
wirklich sagen
[Musik]
stiefel sneaker stöckelschuhe stiefel
klatschen flip flops oder wie die heißen
ja seine marke könnte sagen ja wir
machen noch eine runde unter der ja gut
für dich
die leuchte glühbirne
[Musik]
wenn nicht dann hat aber noch ganz
allgemein formuliert lichtquelle
kraft kündigt stark straßen nicht ich
will - hier sind in die lichte laser ab
lichttechnik links rechts
[Musik]
baustellenampel in den beleuchteten
kadima ist ja auch nicht also ja mit
led-beleuchtung okay das war's vom video
für heute wenn es euch gefallen hat das
gerne glauben hoch da ich würde sagen
aktuell darf noch drei wörter sagen
danke das war's auch schon wieder
[Musik]